madame la Présidente
monsieur le président de la commission
des finances monsieur le rapporteur
général du budget Mesdames et Messieurs
les rapporteurs mesdames et messieurs
les députés
le projet de loi de programmation des
finances publiques est un texte de
responsabilité
responsabilité pour notre souveraineté
les déficits et la dette menacent
l'avenir des jeunes générations
accroisse notre dépendance et réduisent
nos marges de manœuvre
maîtriser nos finances publiques c'est
un gage de souveraineté
pour réussir nous avons besoin
d'objectifs assortis d'un calendrier
c'est précisément ce que permet ce texte
avec une trajectoire crédible pour
baisser le déficit public à 2,7% d'ici
2027 une trajectoire plus ambitieuse que
celle que nous avions prévues
initialement et dont vous aviez débattu
en première lecture
ce projet de loi c'est aussi un texte de
responsabilité
allez s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît
madame la Première ministre allez-y s'il
vous plaît
[Musique]
ce projet de loi c'est aussi un texte de
responsabilité vis-à-vis des Français à
qui nous devons de la clarté sur notre
trajectoire budgétaire et sur les
engagements que nous prenons
[Applaudissements]
il permet de concilier les baisses
d'impôts pour les entreprises et les
ménages et la maîtrise des dépenses
publiques
ce projet de loi c'est un texte de
responsabilité face aux grands défis
devant nous notamment la transition
écologique il prend des engagements
ferme en fixant un objectif ambitieux de
réduction de nos dépenses brunes par
rapport à nos dépenses vertes c'est une
démonstration supplémentaire de notre
volonté d'agir et la garantie que la
planification écologique disposera des
moyens nécessaires
ce projet de loi enfin c'est la
responsabilité vis-à-vis de nos
engagements européens un gage de
crédibilité vis-à-vis de nos partenaires
de la zone euro et une condition pour
obtenir 18 milliards d'euros du plan de
relance de l'Union européenne
ces 18 milliards nous en avons besoin
pour protéger les Français face à
l'inflation pour avancer vers le plein
emploi pour mener la transition
écologique pour améliorer nos services
publics pour assurer l'ordre républicain
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît
mesdames et messieurs les députés la
discussion sur ce texte a commencé il y
a 14 mois
cette année n'a pas été vaine nous avons
pu faire évoluer le projet de loi et
nous avons tenté à nouveau et comme
toujours de trouver des points d'accord
avec les oppositions
cette semaine un vote a eu lieu en
commission et le texte a été adopté
mais après avoir écouté les uns et les
autres je constate qu'au-delà de la
majorité présidentielle aucun groupe
n'est prêt à voter ce texte essentiel
pour notre pays
ce projet de loi a déjà été rejeté en
première lecture nous avons besoin de
cette loi de programmation de nos
finances publiques nous ne pouvons pas
prendre le moindre risque aussi sur le
fondement de l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la
Constitution j'engage la responsabilité
de mon gouvernement sur l'ensemble du
projet de loi de programmation des
finances publiques je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame la Première
ministre pas de claquement de petites
monsieur Tanguy l'Assemblée nationale
prend acte de l'engagement de la
responsabilité du gouvernement
conformément au disposition de l'article
49 à Linéa 3 de la Constitution le texte
sur lequel la première ministre engage
la responsabilité du gouvernement sera
insérée en annexe au compte-rendu de la
présence séance en application de
l'article 155 alinéa premier du
règlement le débat sur ce texte est
immédiatement suspendu ce texte sera
considéré comme adopté sauf si une
motion de censure déposée avant demain
23h58 et votez dans les conditions
prévues à l'article 49 de la
Constitution dans l'hypothèse ou une
motion de censure serait déposée la
Conférence des Présidents fixera la date
et les modalités de sa discussion
prochaine séance demain à 9h suite du
projet de loi pour le plein emploi la
séance est levée